tout vous dire il n'a eu qu'un sondage
il ya un sondage qui est tombé quoi je
tuais baisser les yeux que tu me parles
pas baisser un petit bonne at on alors
elle m'a pas mis sur la touche de mutu
mis sur la touche mais ce que tu vas
faire toi même attaquer maintenant tu as
et boileau nous n'allons ni abri ah oui
alors je vous explique
[Musique]
john breek
voir
passionnée elle caméra tantôt du pays
[Applaudissements]
je
à
[Musique]
mais la dure face à matthieu delormeau
non j'ai pas fait sans moi alors youtube
attention ça va étrange jeu de leurs
mots se prépare on se retrouve dans un
instant lécher les provinces et de tous
par eau potable radio
[Musique]
beck
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
service
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lisbonne